>> Laura: THE FAME FEDERAL
JUDGE OF MEXICAN HERITAGE THAT
CANDIDATE TRUMP SAID WAS BIASED
AGAINST HIM BUT JUST GAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP A HUGE WIN ON
THE BORDER WALL.
U.S. DISTRICT COURT JUDGE RULED
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CAN PROCEED WITH PLANS TO BUILD
A BORDER WALL REGARDLESS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL OBJECTIONS.
I WANT TO GET INTO TODAY'S
SUPREME COURT IMMIGRATION RULING
WITH OUR NEXT GUEST, UNIVISION
AND FUSION ANCHOR JORGE RAMOS,
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF A NEW BOOK I
JUST STARTED "STRANGER: THE
CHALLENGE OF A LATINO IMMIGRANT
IN THE TRUMP ERA" GRATIS IO, HOW
ARE YOU.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK, WHAT IS
YOUR TAKE ON THE SUPREME COURT
RULING THAT CAME DOWN TODAY.
THAT SAID THE BORDER WALL CAN GO
FORWARD WITHOUT THE CONCERN
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL INJECTIONS
IS A LAWSUIT FOLLOWING.
>> THE FIRST THOUGHT IS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT AGAIN THE RACIST
COMMENTS THAT HE MADE ABOUT THE
JUDGE BECAUSE IT'S EXACTLY THE
SAME JUDGE BUT NOW HE SIDED WITH
THE GOVERNMENT.
THAT REMARK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
MADE.
>> Laura: I DON'T LIKE TO
COMMENT ON JUDGES WHEN YOU'RE
BEFORE THE JUDGE ON AN ISSUE, I
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT BUT WHAT
PART OF THAT REMARK WAS RACIST?
HE SAID HE DIDN'T THINK SOMEONE
OF MEXICAN HERITAGE COULD RULE
ON IMMIGRATION RELATED MATTERS
BECAUSE OF THE DUAL LOYALTY?
>> WHEN YOU THINK THAT SOMEONE
CAN'T DO HIS JOB SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF HIS HERITAGE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID IT BECAUSE
HE WAS OF MEXICAN HERITAGE, HE
COULDN'T DO HIS JOB DEALING ON
TRUMP UNIVERSITY.
IT'S THE SAME WAY IT IS A RACIST
STATEMENT TO SAY THAT PEOPLE
FROM HAITI AND AFRICAN NATIONS
ARE FROM S-WHOLE COUNTRIES.
>> Laura: WE KNOW THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA USE DEROGATORY
LANGUAGE ABOUT OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE KNOW THAT OTHER COUNTRIES
HAVE DONE THE SAME THING.
ON THE ISSUE OF RACISM
PARTICULARLY, YOU MAKE WHILE THE
CHARGES IN YOUR BOOK THAT WE ARE
GOING TO GET INTO A JUST A
MOMENT.
THERE WAS ANOTHER CASE THAT CAME
DOWN THE COURT IT WAS A 5-3
RULING THAT SAID AT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT CAN INDEFINITELY
DETAIN INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FOUND
AT THE BORDER OR EVEN GREEN CARD
TO QUESTION THEIR LEGAL STATUS,
THAT WAS A 5-3 RULING, YOUR
REACTION TO THAT.
>> IS NOT EASY TO BE IN
IMMIGRATION NOWADAYS THE
UNITED STATES.
MANY IMMIGRANTS FEEL --
>> Laura: ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT,
YOU ALWAYS DO THIS AND IT DRIVES
PEOPLE NUTS.
>> I DON'T CALL THEM IN LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE NO ONE IS
ILLEGAL IN THIS WORLD.
>> Laura: WHAT ARE THEY CALL
THEM IN MEXICO?
>> THEIR UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
>> THEIR UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
IMMIGRANTS.
IT IS INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO
BE AN IMMIGRANT IN THIS COUNTRY.
DONALD TRUMP HAS MADE IT A
HOSTILE NATION FOR MANY
IMMIGRANTS, UNDOCUMENTED
UNDOCUMENTED.
>> Laura: LATINO UNEMPLOYMENT
IS AT A RECORD LOW, THAT'S NOT A
GOOD STATISTIC FOR YOU?
>> I THINK THAT'S POSITIVE WHEN
IT COMES TO ECONOMICS BUT HOW
ABOUT IF YOU ARE A FAMILY WHOSE
FATHER OR MOTHER HAS BEEN
DEPORTED.
HOW ABOUT IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THE TRUMP GOVERNMENT
HAS ARRESTED.
ARRESTS IN TRUMP'S FIRST YEAR
ARE 30% HIGHER THAN THE LAST
YEAR OF BARACK OBAMA.
SURE UNEMPLOYMENT IS BETTER FOR
LATINO, DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN
ARRESTED MANY MORE PEOPLE THAN
BARACK OBAMA.
>> Laura: LET'S GET AN
ANSWER -- I'M A SIMPLE PERSON AT
THE BOTTOM OF ALL THIS.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS DO YOU
BELIEVE IN NATIONHOOD?
>> I BELIEVE THAT EVERY SINGLE
ITS BORDER.
>> Laura: TWO COUNTRIES HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DETERMINE WHO COMES
INTO THE COUNTRY AND WHO MUST
LEAVE THEIR COUNTRY?
DO THEY HAVE THAT SOVEREIGN
RIGHT?
>> I BELIEVE THAT BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE PARTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR 11 MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
IN THIS COUNTRY SIMPLY BECAUSE
WE BENEFIT FROM THEIR WORK EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THE FOOD THAT WE EAT THE HOMES
THAT THEY ARE BUILDING TO THE
CHILDREN THAT THEY TAKE CARE OF.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS PAY
TAXES.
>> Laura: NOT ALL OF THEM.
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE GET CASH UNDER
THE TABLE.
EVERY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT RESCUES
A CAT FROM A TREE.
THERE WAS ALSO A DOCTOR
RECIPIENT WHO WAS ARRESTED FOR
MAKING THREATS AGAINST THE
SCHOOL.
EVERY TIME WE HEAR DACA, WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO THINK THEIR FUTURE
VALEDICTORIANS.
WE HAVE A RIGHT AS ABIGAIL
HERNANDEZ, SHE WAS ARRESTED IN
FEDERAL DETENTION UP IN YONKERS
ARRESTED FOR MAKING A THREAT
AGAINST THE SCHOOL SHE DIDN'T
ATTEND -- EVERY TIME YOU SAY
IT'S BAD FOR IMMIGRANTS IN THE
UNITED STATES, WHY DO SO MANY
PEOPLE WANT TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY IF THIS IS A COUNTRY
THAT IS NOT WELCOMING TO LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS?
TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE FAITH IN THE
SYSTEM AND FOLLOW THE LAW, NOT
TO THOSE WHO BREAK THE LAW AND
THEN EXPECT SPECIAL BENEFITS ON
THE OTHER SIDE?
>> ARE YOU CRIMINALIZING
2 MILLION --
>> Laura: THAT'S THE GAME
YOU'RE PLAYING IF NO ONE BUYS
IT.
>> IT WOULD BE THE SAME WAY IF I
WERE TO SAY ALL HISPANICS WERE
LIKE THE MEN WHO KILLED PEOPLE
IN LAS VEGAS.
OR WHAT ADAM LANZA DID INSTANTLY
HOOK.
YOU CANNOT CRIMINALIZE.
>> Laura: THEY ARE ALREADY
HERE UNLAWFULLY, WE DON'T HAVE
TO CRIMINALIZE THEM.
>> THEN DON'T.
BECAUSE OF ONE CASE, ALL THE
DREAMERS -- THEY ARE NOT.
>> Laura: IN THE END, THIS
COUNTRY IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY
IN MY VIEW, I KNOW YOU ARE BOTH
A CITIZEN OF MEXICO YOU VOTE IN,
CORRECT?
>> I VOTED MEXICO AND THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO
VOTE FOR AND MAKE A        PENAN
VOTE FOR AND MAKE A        PENAE
VOTE FOR AND MAKE A        PENAO
VOTE FOR AND MAKE A        PENA?
>> I THINK PRESIDENT PENA NIETO
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE WORST
PRESIDENTS, HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
COURAGE TO TELL PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS FACE THAT MEXICO WAS NOT
GOING TO PAY FOR THE WALL.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK IN THE
END MEXICO WILL FORGE A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA INSTEAD
OF RENEGOTIATING NAFTA AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE A GOOD THING
FOR MEXICO?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE A GOOD THING FOR MEXICO.
IF YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, MEXICO WON'T PAY
FOR THAT WALL.
>> I THINK MEXICO MIGHT PAY SOME
OF IT INDIRECTLY.
>> I DON'T SEE THAT.
>> Laura: WE MIGHT HAVE A
WHOLE NEW BUSINESS ARRANGEMENT
THAT WOULD BE GOOD FOR BOTH OF